er ist hat wieder ein vollidiot
ich habe euch bei instagram gefragt was
ich heute hochladen soll entweder einen
reaction video oder ein gaming video
dabei kam das hier raus also falls ihr
auch entscheiden wollt was sich
hochladen instagram da kommst in san
luca
wie reagieren heute auf jeden fall
gemeinsam auf die hilfe folge hauptsache
in der gang koste es was es wolle
und wie wir das immer machen würde ich
sagen bevor wir uns das video anschauen
schauen wir erst einmal in die
kommentare wer findet die von der gang
auch voll hässlich gegen diese coole
gang ist sogar die 6 aus der baumschule
cool würde niemals so einen mist machen
nur um mit papis kindern abzuhängen und
die besten schauspielkünste hatte der
zug nicht vergessen die derartige
dialoge aus fertigen werden dafür
bezahlt war wohin geht die welt
produzent wie viele schimpfwörter wollt
ihr rtl 2 ja ja und was natürlich auch
nicht fehlen darf ist der kommentar ich
freue mich schon auf lukas reaktionen
und die passiert jetzt
dies ist ganz einfach du springst auf
den nächsten zug
[Musik]
erster sonst eher gesagt wir es ganz
einfach du springst auf den nächsten zug
und fährt bis zur nächsten haltestelle
also freunde
ich glaube wirklich dass sie irgendwie
das oberhaupt von der gang ist und sie
macht jetzt eine ansage an irgend ein
mädel die in die gänge kommen will
aber wir haben erst sechs sekunden
geschaut also ich würde sagen wir gucken
wir weiter haben doch total gefährlich
sagen okay also sie wild wirklich in die
gruppe und diese drei leute sind diese
gang
wer will nicht in gang bestehend aus
einer da bedienen ich weiß wie meine cap
trägt einer person die es wird auch
immer das von linksys und die traurigen
bandana aber trotzdem zog martin ja auch
keinen sinn aber die damit die unbedingt
in die gegen ryan will hat jetzt auch
nicht so
also ich meine sie der ein t shirt wo
draufsteht keep calm and safety videos
16 sekunden alt und ich bin schon drei
mal klatschen durch manches mal gelaufen
sagen was tust du das mal gar nix machen
zu wollen
[Musik]
diese eine komische die diese kämpfe
nicht richtig tragen kann sagt
diskutiert nicht mit uns rum macht gar
nichts macht das was wir wollen
soll sie jetzt gar nichts machen oder
soll sie das machen was ihr wollt
helsinki einzeln habt ihr's wir haben es
gemacht
stell dir vor die sind alle auf den
fahrenden zug gesprungen von der brücke
hier was wissen sprechen
ich habe es bewusst man müsste passieren
ich stecke bisher gar nichts hat sie
überhaupt den sinn von lippenstift
verstanden alter oder die etwa herpel
zum helm nazi belaufen können jetzt auch
zu gehen die mutprobe weicht ober kraft
das kannst du dir nicht vorstellen dass
heute von einer brücke auf einen zug
springen
das war unmöglich das hättest du auch
nicht gemacht
[Musik]
du solltest wollen fabrik aufzug
sprechers die armee gastieren im ersten
apfel
wer schreibt diese texte es ist mein
größter traum sie werden heute von jedem
respektiert ja aber ich will jetzt auch
nicht mein leben für die riskieren oder
würdest du das machen ja das würde ich
zitiere mal sandra wer euch ins hirn
geschissen also klar das ist alles nur
schauspiel et cetera pp und wenn ich
irgendwie was sage oder keine ahnung was
dann geht's auch das heißt ja immer
nicht gegen die leute die hinter den
rollen stehen sondern nur gegen die
gespielte rolle also ich möchte
niemanden beleidigen oder sonst war es
allerdings frage ich mich dennoch wieder
leute wirklich bei rtl2 sitzen können
und sich denken können
ja die serie heißt eigentlich jung
pleite verzweifelt aber kommen wir tun
wir so als wäre dann medien und die wird
unbedingt in der gruppe rein aber dann
sagt die gruppe die soll von der brücke
springen auf dem zug und jona sollte
sich überlegen ob sie wirklich zur
mädchen gang gehören möchte ich kann
hier nur raten extrem vorsichtig zu sein
wenn freunde kann man nicht kaufen und
ihre freunde macht man auch keine
mutprobe
das hat natürlich eine gute aussage von
der müsste ja die ganze zeit rumlungern
könnte es nicht woanders machen da auch
nur ein kratzer ist dann gibt's richtig
ärgert euch doch mal an was willst du
eigentlich was sein wird das wird heute
noch ein falsches worten du kannst du
bist lass ich mal eine woche
[Musik]
mach dir mal die hände nicht an diesen
steckdosen befruchten schmutzig machen
frage ist was willst du denn von uns so
hey leute das mit der aktion auf der
brücke richtung mir verleidet hat eine
zweite chance verdient oder habe zwar
gesagt es geht
[Musik]
der vater bleibt user und die kriegen ja
vielleicht noch eine idee wir sind doch
noch eine zweite chance bekommt und was
wäre das was da nicht machen jetzt
bleibt man ruhig milchschnitte ich habe
gesagt vielleicht
milch schnitte die milch-schnitte
überhaupt eine beleidigung also ich
feiere milchschnitte seid ihr eher die
milchschnitte oder team kinder pinguin
das wird mich auch mal interessieren
weil viele von meinen freunden team
kinder pinguin ich bin eigentlich eher
team
die haben doch die teilen sich doch
jeder eine gehirnverletzung nicht
verstanden verstanden ich krieg das sind
was soll ich machen
wir haben nicht eine mutprobe für dich
sondern drei ich wenn ich dann alle drei
stehe dann bin ich ja rechnen
dann musst du sie erstmal bestehen was
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt drei so kann jeder von
uns hat eine prophetische kleiner würde
die haben die ganzen sei der herr ist
denn da los wirst du schwer von begriff
oder was du sollst sein wagen clown die
karre vor dem nachbar cloud dass ich
erwischt
naja tottenham ich hoffe ich auch getan
[Musik]
dort hätte aber ich glaube die teile die
zu dritt vielleicht eine viertel gehirns
hätte mehr von dir erwartet kleine junge
leute wartet ich krieg das schon hin
aber die knackigen auto ist dass unser
problem oder war ich hab dir schon mal
gesagt willst du zu uns gehören lass dir
was ein die hast du deine karre die
dukaten soll
ok ich hoffe du hast den dreh langsam
raus bekommen
und ja box gar nicht okay also sie
klasse
ich habe jetzt schon einmal hier wird es
nicht so rund
hallo halb voll recht krass aktion war
würden wir gehen jetzt erst mal party
machen ein paar sekunden später chillige
party tagsüber in irgend einem park mit
fanta und wasser als soll dagegen will
ich tatsächlich dann auch gern gehören
navy oder zeigt an was du drauf hast sie
den spagat probe täglich bei uhren
alltägliche zu uns also zeit sie sollen
jetzt abziehen das hat er wahrscheinlich
auch gar nicht gehört dem problem hast
du ein problem
nein ich habe keins ja klar ist die
unterhaltung das ist ja an sich das
anzuschauen
das ist ganz im ernst sich das
anzuschauen ist ja schon fremdscham
genug aber wie prinz muss es sein wenn
du da schauspieler bisher daran
mitarbeiten sondern folge ein konto ein
kondom
das waren 2 madame 21 euro ich glaube
das sind jetzt meine da war mein
taschengeld davon wollte ich was
wolltest du damit neue kondome für moby
und ich kaufen oder war
was geht denn da die sache zur anzeige
kommt dann wird es hier sicherlich keine
sozialstunden mehr geben vor dem
hintergrund des kfz diebstahls in höchst
fahrens ohne führerschein sicht
wahrscheinlichen kurzfristigen
jugendarrest
ja da bin ich ja wirklich brennend
interessiert an der weiteren zukunft von
viola allerdings will ich an der stelle
das heutige jetzt erst mal beendet meine
lieben freunde wenn euch die reaction ja
heute auf diese hilfe folge gefallen hat
dann das unbedingt einen daumen hoch
unter dem video da wird nicht wirklich
sehr sehr doll freundin schreibt mir
gerne in die kommentare
via zwischendrin schon gefragt sagt der
team milchschnitte oder team kinder
pinguin ich weiß nicht irgendwie beides
leisten das ist ja auch kein placement
aber es hat mich nur gerade interessiert
weil die ich für dich heißt diese eine
komisch ja irgendwie das wort milch
schnitte als beleidigung genutzt keine
ahnung wo man so was macht aber deswegen
frage ich mich einfach
seid ihr auch er die milch schnitte er
team kinder pinguin ja eigentlich ist es
egal denn das video jetzt vorbei wenn
ihr noch kein abonnent zeit auf meinem
kanal würde ich mich sehr freuen
naja können die unter dem video machen
akon auf die glocke klicken dann bekommt
er eine benachrichtigung wenn ich nur
ein video hochladen passiert ja fast
täglich und sonstigem ein pulli aus weil
es unfassbar heiß in köln
[Musik]